now a pass ahead for Michael McLoud the first
round pick in 2016 brat drops it off here's
Hamilton shoots it up high and a blocker save by
vinning another shot in the slot blocked there
maybe by Shen Hamilton again fires it back
goes dri wide and off the cloud and now BR
picks it up at the line Hamilton right on goal
save by Bennington rebound shot wide and now it
comes around to Kyu up the ice with saw and they
crisscross Kyu from the angle and a sa by Schmidt
leading the NHL and scoring with 20 points he
is tough to contain here's a shot from the wing
right on goal by Lazar who has scored the Blue's
only Power Play goal this [Applause] year and a
scramble there kept in capping it and he walks
in fires it on goal and a save by Schmid Thomas
and neighbors into the zone now Robert Thomas
waiting tanks it back for Nick Ley now Ley back
shot got through and a save by Schmidt and the
Devils played it the line L kept it alive now
neers puts it back on goal and a save Again by
Schmid here's faul now for crew nice passing in
for neighbors neighbors waiting shoots it on
goal and it's save by spit it bounced up off
his stick and nearly over his shoulder metal bles
at the line with davage he can't move it in tied
up there with Meyer now he was up the middle
he darts right in and a saved by bton on Jack
Hughes who goes down and he's hurt happened to
him not sure if he hit his leg or his shoulder
now he jks through the Blue's defense on that one
there and loses his footing right after the shot
attempt on Jordan Bennington here's krug's pass
Shen going down now bunded ahead by sod the Kyo
tow drag around Hughes in un goal and a save there
by shid Ona after a Nifty play by Kyo tend to go
in the power play no neighbors ahead s he's in the
clear and a backhander and a save by shid nearly
a short-handed goal for S this particular play
here the stick is under the arm in inter Quine
I felt like that should have absolutely been a
penalty Jacob trying to get it that will keep it
alive five and now Center Bastion with it shoots
it on goal and it's saved by Bennington over over
and then too trying to get away from traffic and
that'll Blu is to Center Jamie you had a good look
at that break by S was that a a good none call
I'm still puzzled as to how that wasn't a penalty
on the devil's defender in fact I was thinking
penalty shot one point now T Sho to kyou he goes
wide on Smith and on goal backhander and it's
save byid and the blue is 45 to go in the power
play here's Hayes with it he holds on to it down
the far WIS ronic to the net and a sa by spit it's
loose there for ful looking for B davic at the
back now again L David in front capping it right
in shoots it on goal and a save by Schmid bothered
a bit by Sun twist here come the doubles to Center
Meyers checked by Le and then a pass to Blake
into the neighbors into the CLA shs he scores Jake
neighbors and the blows have taken a one- nothing
[Music] laad boy what a fantastic goal there
by the blues great great execution by the blues
fourth line watch Oscar sunquist here nice little
pass from the Sammy bla little backhand sauce
over to Jake neighbors who makes no no mistake
but right here little hot sauce right there Jake
Neighbors comes in see if they have a faceof play
here off a win he gets it cleanly back for Ley
Ley to Veron the drive and a save rebound lety
is shot rebound they score Kevin Hayes his first
goal is a blow and it's two nothing they set it up
Nick lety down the boards this was a set play for
Verana with a one timer there and then again again
where do you go if you want to score goals in the
National Hockey League you go to the front of the
net because things like this happen and you end
up getting your first goal of the season and Kevin
Hayes right there he celebrates so the former NCAA
Champion out of Boston College with 18 goals last
year gets his first as a blow now the devil's
in and a great right patch save by [Applause]
benington what a chance there for br and draon
may have saved the goal there but this is a long
way from being over oh yeah you got to keep
your foot on the gas absolutely Faulk fell
down here's paot in and a save by benington
it's under his right pad and now Meyer with
it and he waits in the ball shoots it and where
is it maybe in the equipment run support so to
speak this shooting for the blues gold Tinder L
to up two tonight now Marino comes in in front
PS a shot rebound and they score as the Devils
Marino got the rebound and makes it a 2-1 game
they managed to get one here right off the face
off gold Breo Nick lety read the play perfectly
on that one and then they're rewarded there as
Curtis Lazar gets a chance but Nick lety looking
for the pass and Marino was right up on that
one closing it out good block shot there but
Jordan Bennington can only do so much on that but
Nick Ley at Center Ice H by him Devils came in
to Foley in front the Meyer and a great save by
Bennington on team o Meer but right before that
Jordan Bennington watch this what a push side to
side and crew long pass kyou what a feed the saw
better pass to hay in on goal back and front and
he missed a wide openen goal I do not believe it
and played around cut off the look out in
front and a shot on goal by Meyer and a save
by Bennington Matt scramble there devils again
and to Foley can't believe it it went out of
play or did Bennington save it I don't know it
must have gone out of [Applause] [Music] play
this is Tory crew coming across there Tyler
to fully sneak in back door and right here
maybe off the crossbar maybe put it on net
or if nothing else get it down behind the
oppositions net can't be turning it over
passing the puck sideways now 150 left
doubles with the goalie off they dump it in
bing 10 plays it Breo clears it up the wall
knocked away Hayes with it Hayes a shot and he
scores it's second tonight empty n 3-1 good guys
and just like that he totally redeems himself but
Jordan Bennington starts it Colton Paro and then
Kevin Hayes nice little glove there grabbing it
out of the air and then being right down here at
ice level John I can tell you he didn't even
look right or left he was staring down at the
opposition's net here's folk Tays a third chance
for the hattrick instead a pass off the crossbar
by davish now haes another chance here's Fulk
and he waits pis he scores Another Empty Netter
as the blues finally hit the empty net again his
hatrick narrowly getting missing on that one there
couple of good opportunities but I think that uh
Kevin Hayes he got a little tuckered out there
towards the end of this ship and then ultimately
it goes down to Robert Thomas he's all by himself
he scores and then well they did their best to get
a he the hatrick yeah they did but Thomas does get
it at 1950 and that's going to do it as the blues
will win it and snap a two game losing Street